e obrigado pelo convite eu devo dizer
que pensa em respeito ea primeira coisa
que pensei foi um dos meus avós nos meus
avós porque talvez sejam as pessoas que
mais falam isso com aquela casinha
negativa
acho que a condição de ser a volta no
tempo em que era no tempo em que havia
respeito a nossos países e ninguém
respeita ninguém e e fez pensar muito
sobre o que é isto dodô respeito
enquanto aquela coisa que nós
valorizamos só mesmo quando ela nos faz
falta
nunca em uma trilha no iphone com a
internet como ela precisava mas com a
particularidade de o exigir um chip não
é como aquelas vezes em que vamos ao
café ter mágoas pedras nos dizem que só
tem frisos e nós dizemos a câmera não
com respeito
nós exigimos água das pedras de marca da
água das pedras com gelo e não só
precisa e nunca tivemos deus e por nunca
prosseguirmos desta coisa destas coisas
que valorizamos só quando nos fazem
falta e quando o exigimos ser sempre
numa lógica de estarmos melhores uns com
os outros
estávamos bem eu escolhi também falar
sobre política
eu creio que isso funcionasse como sair
com o respeito com uma coisa que os avós
sempre os meus avós que estão sempre a
dizer que há uma frase antiga que disso
é uma frase antiga que é só isso
a antiga antiga também é política há
muito tempo e eu escolhi falar sobre
política porque tem uma carga positiva e
nós não é hoje a coisa mais respeitada
do mundo dizem ons
outros dizem que ela também nos não só
respeito e pra mim é assim que tenho com
esta panela de água fervente
é uma coisa de memória curta mas com o
impacto a longo prazo e de longa duração
e esta coisa do do respeito pela
política por esta água a ferver cheia de
um sonho sem contradições cheia de
decisões cheia de nós todos têm uma
máxima é uma máxima muito engraçada que
isso quem quer falar política hoje
começa sempre por enumerar todos os
preconceitos que tem contra ela como
sempre dizer que não precisamos dela
não queremos saber disso para nada nem
vai ficar com isso
acontece muito na minha geração também
não precise se chama trabalhava tinha de
estar embaixo
estamos hoje muito mais atenção à
corrupção do que a má política
jogamos a política sempre pelo que devia
ter feito mas nunca pelo que fez e
podemos dizer todas estas coisas sobre a
política e fazer essas acusações todas
sobre política porque a política fraca
que a fraca por duas razões uma delas é
que a incerteza e desconfiança entre
toda a gente pensar todas as consultas
não acredito isso há sempre a certeza ea
política não se queixem de incerteza as
pessoas que decidem por nós pelo
coletivo tem sempre incerteza na decisão
que a carregava de incerteza como é
carregada de tentar controlar o que não
consegue a segunda coisa que faço da
política uma coisa fraca é que cada dia
que passa ela controla - o que passa à
sua volta e por quê porque ficou mais
livre da liberdade às pessoas para
criarem prazer em para escolherem
enfrentarmos um breve nunca se forem da
internet
referendamos o aborto mas nunca sofrendo
mutação genética porque as pessoas
inventam e vão sempre inventar mais a
sociedade vai sempre estar a inventar e
conforme a política vai tendo mais
dificuldade em controlar o que se passa
à sua volta mais dificuldade têm também
os políticos justificar alguns
privilégios cutâneo por uma missão
continua ou pode perder importância para
uma missão pode ser menos vem
desempenhava e nós cá continuamos a
dizer que não prestam a desrespeitá los
e assim a dizer que os outros diz
respeito a nós a uma coisa no entanto
devemos saber sempre é que a política é
vulnerável e sempre que fazemos os
nossos políticos mais vulneráveis
fazemos do nosso estado mais vulnerável
e fazemos nós próprios também mais
vulneráveis
esta coisa dizer que a política são
incompetentes é o bando de incompetentes
quarentão
devia preocupado a pessoa que vi isso é
o que eu pergunto sempre seu sonho como
tempo de bastão tá tudo bem conheço quem
perguntar isso de se preocupar o governo
chateado
acho que está na política para uma coisa
é para se incomodar pela história como
data foi ela que mudou tudo
às vezes com mais força outras vezes não
quando era em regime de total de
turistas mudava a ansiedade mudar vamos
nós
como tem metas para guerra naquela água
a ferver entra com uma forma entre risos
e inclusivo tentou lançar e mudava tudo
ficaram em regimes mais democráticos no
mundo há tanta coisa
é como pôr um ovo adentro entramos com
uma forma saiu o ovo com a mesma forma
mas muda por dentro e tem mudado assim
muitas vezes muitas coisas a
temperaturas diferentes formas
diferentes e agora tem um novo desafio
que é uma coisa que eu gosto de chamar
uma nova ordem mundial para que eu possa
estar das pessoas e que é muito
engraçada festa falou
esta é a razão pela qual as nossas
empresas vão deixar de prestar tanta
atenção ao preço o qual vendeu o produto
porque vão começar a dar bola para
ganhar isto valores é razão pela qual
nós nos vamos mirar aqui todos em boas
intervenções para ganhar favores é o
capital que leva um artista é o capital
que cometam um projeto é o capital que o
medo de uma organização é o capital como
um político
o número do ex o número de seguidores e
hoje toda a gente segue isto toda a
gente se esforça por ter mais falou
assim mais views mais likes grande
sentido o grande desafio da política e
que se viu isto muito rápido e inclusiva
com isso da mesma forma que o ecrã e da
conosco porque os pixels do e credo
então todas as contas - amarelo e ainda
assim estarão sempre que o via amarela
na televisão sintam enganados porque é
só a vossa opressão
ele só aparecem três com rimas
josé melo mas o nosso cérebro os nossos
olhos têm a obsessão do que a wii
amarelo
é como o passivo também nos dá a
sensação que temos assegurados não
estamos a fazer nada nos dá força para
continuar e é difícil explicar isto deve
explicar ele próprio se vermos porque as
coisas acontecem assim na ciência é
sempre bom saber por que é que acontece
qual é a razão para não estarmos a
perceber aquilo assim desta forma óbvia
atividade é um dos ofícios da ciência ir
além dos limites da pretensão de ir além
do que as pessoas conseguem ver com os
próprios olhos e de explicar isso é bom
gosto
já na política é objetividade é uma
coisa complica
mas tantas coisas a objetividade na
política não é a coisa mais fácil para
um político porque é e se combatem as
pessoas sentidos
hoje é muito mais fácil ter falou horas
atrás de uma mentira
fácil explicar do que uma verdade
difícil de compreender que as pessoas
seguem isto por uma razão mesmo mesmo
mesmo muito simples porque todos nós
pensamos com narrativas
todos nós pensamos com construções sobre
factos
tomamos decisões sobre histórias muito
mais rápidos sobre as narrativas e as
construções e as histórias do que os
factos nem se muito mais rápido nos
convencem por isso do pornô -
pornográficos ou por outra coisa
qualquer
e essa capacidade de criar a narrativa
da pressão política pessoa muito bem e
hoje temos política de pressão
quem faz política da oposição que as
coisas estão muito bem está tudo ótimo
quem faz política também na apreciação
do que eu não está tudo bem está tudo
mal e é por isso que é bom ter um
contraditório e aqui que estamos a meio
da ponta mas a ponte quer dizer que nós
devíamos estar indignados porque não
estamos a ser respeitados porque estão a
dar trabalho a cobra continua desejo
estão a dar uma obsessão uma construção
uma narrativa sobre uma coisa dizem
estar preocupados também porque
respeitamos pouco costa e uma da ponte
fácil escolher entre estar duas formas
na política não está porque a política é
o único poder é que as pessoas que não
têm poder podem alcançar perdermos a
política pode não significar nada agora
é vida normal como é normal quando temos
3g do iphone é normal quando aparece uma
desgraça e podemos ter duas formas de
mostrar como uma pedra aqui dentro da
pedra vai entrar vai ter pra ver
ela vai sair exatamente igual e tentar
passivos podemos ser assim e assim vamos
ser os grandes aliados de todas as
pessoas que vêem na política e na
negativa do contrário o grande obstáculo
para fazerem exatamente o que quer
conquistar passivos que as pessoas
gostam para seguir os seus interesses
pessoais
vamos agradecer - podemos por outro a
vão descrever a narrativa em vez de
sermos uma pedra
vamos ter um café vamos entrar vamos ver
vamos sair exatamente iguais mas agora
vai ficar de frente
obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]